إنها مساعدة كبيرة جدًا الآن للشعب الأوكراني
لأن لدينا الآن مشكلة كبيرة جدًا
في أوكرانيا
لأن الكثير من الناس
سيذهبون من شرق أوكرانيا إلى غرب
أوكرانيا
ونحتاج إلى
صنع
المزيد من الطعام
والحومر حيث يمكننا البقاء
والراحة مع
طفلك لذلك نحن  هل سننشئ
شبكة توزيع نقدي
مع شركاء محليين أوكرانيين
للتأكد من أنه يمكننا تحويل النقود
حتى يتمكن الأشخاص المحتاجون في
المدن والبلدات المختلفة من
شراء
السلع التي يحتاجون إليها بالفعل.
لا أعتقد أن أي مساعدة يمكننا
تقديمها في الوقت الحالي ستكون كافية
لهذا الوضع المدمر ولكني
أعتقد أن ما يمكننا تقديمه سيساعد
الأشخاص الذين يمكننا مساعدتهم
لذلك عندما تكون عالقًا في ملجأ أو
تحت  الجسر
وتحتاج إلى الماء ، فأنت بحاجة إلى بطانيات ، فأنت
بحاجة إلى طعام سيساعد الكثير من
الأفراد ، لكنه
حالة طبية كبيرة جدًا